this is
the ramsey show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
is my co-host today which means we can
talk about your money
and your careers ken helps in 75 cities
siriusxm and a very popular podcast
every day answering your questions about
getting a
job oh that or a better career yeah you
know
i'm talking about helping you get the
income you need
and making the impact you want we're
combining impact and income
so you and i are like the one-two punch
i'm the one that says be cheap and
you're the one says increase your income
yes but be cheap while increasing the
income and we get out of the baby steps
faster
that's it yeah all right and oh and by
the way enjoy your work
it turns out dave that we at ramsey
solutions believe that you were created
to work to actually contribute it's
about
yourself you just said people are
supposed to work be careful that's
probably that's an unpopular message
these days i was speaking in orlando
yesterday and i was telling them the
story of us sending our people home
to work from home and i reminded them
that part of that phrase says work
yeah while you're at home the first word
yeah work yeah while you're at home got
a good laugh
oh bad yeah yeah it's kind of nice i had
uh 3 000 folks in a live audience
yesterday in orlando how did that feel
oh like heaven for a speaker
i have not just being backstage and
putting a mic on facebook
i saw that i've never seen you actually
take a picture or post a picture
of just empty uh audio visual boxes
which is what you did and i knew i
smiled i was like
yeah you're just excited to be back the
team that went down with me i'll show
you guys
speaking for re max national convention
international convention
and uh they the team that went down with
me uh we're like
okay i feel so good at work yeah i feel
so good to get out here
and do what we do which is communicate
with human freaking beings
it's just nice yeah the energy had to be
palpable
man because you got to know those people
were dying to be in that audience too
no pun intended yeah easy dave someone's
going to misquote you
because we know how unsafe we've been
because you're
because of my direction that's right my
lack of uh my lack of knowledge of covet
oh lord jesus help us all right open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five jeff is in lexington
kentucky to start off
the day on this hour hey jeff how are
you
okay doing good ken dave ken real quick
i called your
show about a month ago with a question
about my resume
and i did what you told me to do because
i had an interview the next day
i got the job and i start one week from
today come on
here we go jeff the coleman the coleman
magic resume trick
so what was what was his magic resume
trick what did he tell you to do
just to tighten it up because it was a
little bit my job description
was a little bit too much what i had in
there and it had gone over to a second
page
and he said just to tighten it up and
condense it down and you can get it to a
page
that was your magic well dave you know
that's like me telling people to live on
less than they make yeah i was gonna say
what's so magical about rice and beans
none of those beans you would recommend
are magical
no but you know what here's the thing
about jeff so i remember the call now
jeff and i'm gonna tell you something
what people do is they feel like they
got to put their entire work biography
in there
and the reality is that people that are
hiring they're looking for one thing
do we think jeff can help us win and he
tightened it he gave him the relevant
work experience
we know that hiring manager spent 7.4
seconds dave
scanning a resume so just do that in
your head at home that's how much
you're 4.7 no you said 4.7 i'm under
that
i'm half the national average anyway all
right jeff how can we help you today
well i had a question my investment
advisor and i are having with this
agreement as to whether i should use the
beneficiary of my beneficiary ira to pay
off debt and what it is my wife and i
are on baby step two
and i'm wanting to do this over the
course of like the next 24 months
so that we can get 100 debt free we've
got
basically a buffet of debt we've got
credit cards
two car loans some student loan debt and
a home equity line of credit
uh i'm 53 i don't have any retirement
savings of my own
my wife is 52 and she's got about
thousand a 401k
through her employer and where my
investment advisor disagreeing on this
is she's concerned to do this it's gonna
kick me up from a 12
tax bracket up to a 24 for the next two
years
and of course loss of you know principle
in that time with being able to earn i'm
not wanting to cash the whole thing out
which would be an even bigger tax hit of
like 37
and just trying to figure out what the
best way
to do this is you know just how much
depth are you having on the situation
how much should it be
all together to 136 000 is that your
house too
that's the that's the home effort when i
credit yes sir the house was paid for
we're not here a debt free house and
everything with 130 grand
136 yeah okay and how much is in this
inherited ira
right now it's uh 441
okay and what's your household income
projected i've been out of work for the
last year but projected for the rest of
this year
89 000. okay this is mathematically
incorrect in the short term but
it has all kinds of data to back up the
advice
i would pay it all off tomorrow and pay
the taxes well you need to keep in mind
a 37
tax bracket it does not mean 100 of the
funds are taxed at 37
it means the last dollars are taxed we
have a marginal tax bracket a graduated
tax bracket
so the first so many dollars are taxed
at zero the next so many dollars are
taxed at twelve this next so many
dollars are taxed at twenty the next so
many dollars a tax
and that's what the tax brackets do it
doesn't when you bump a tax bracket make
your whole income taxed at that bracket
it's only those last few dollars that
are taxed at that bracket all of that's
going to be offset by the fact that you
got rid of
all this interest that you're paying
you're 100 free cash flow
now the only way this advice works is if
you follow the rest of
our program which means dude you roll up
your sleeves and become an investment
maniac your baby step seven
and you start investing a house payment
you fill up all your retirements
you max out everything everything you
can get your hands on and you start
throwing mutual funds like a crazy man
and you use a big
chunk of your income i want you to
invest everything you can put max out
all your 401ks all your roth iras
i want you to and then invest a house
payment above that
and any loss you have due to this having
cash this out early
will be recouped in 24 to 36 months
okay if you don't do the last part if
you don't do the last part her idea is
right
okay should i just cash out enough to
no pay off all the debt yeah oh that's
all just enough to pay off all the debt
and the taxes what are tax bills created
by it
because you don't have the money to pay
the taxes right no
so it's 150 grand
okay and you got 250 left and you have
this huge income
and you have zero payments and you're
going to invest all of them and you're
going to be a millionaire
in 36 months run the math out i'm right
okay but the problem
with people in the investment world is
all of us that grew up in that world
have seen everybody not do the second
part
after they did the first part and then
you retire with a lot less money
because you paid off all your debt and
then you kept spending and then you
spent more
and you weren't on a budget and you
didn't follow through and you didn't max
out all your retirement like we teach
you to do in baby step seven
max out everything and if you don't
raise your right hand and promise to do
that
don't follow part of my advice it'll
hurt you follow
all of it it'll make you rich because
i'm what's known as
right this is the ramsay show
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we talk about careers
jobs and your life and your money that's
what the ramsay show is all about it's
all about
you you're the subject turns out you're
pretty dadgum entertaining i'll just say
dustin's in kansas city hi dustin how
can we help
hey dave sorry i'm a little nervous i've
been watching you for the last year and
a
half
no troubles man we never lost a patient
what's up uh
i got about this is my third house i
bought i flipped the first one second
one i
was planning on flipping but it had some
septic issues
i didn't get as big of a return on it
i'm on my third one i have a year and a
half old daughter
um it's getting hard on me my wife and
my daughter to keep flipping these
houses and living in them
um oh this is the last house i got i got
about
so far 30 000 into it i got about 50 000
equity equity i'm just trying to get an
idea of what i should do i got about 25
000 in my bank account
and just trying to get an idea what's
next what do you do for a living
uh i work for a roofing company okay
good for you
okay what's your household income uh
about 46 000 right now
okay so i heard your plan is if i
understood you correctly to stop
flipping because you're tired of moving
or at least your wife is and um
with a baby and all that it makes it
hard and so you're going to settle in
are you going to settle in on this
property are you going to flip this one
out and buy the one that you settle into
i think that's the goal is after this
one to be done
for a little while at least okay because
you didn't pick this one out to live in
you picked it out to flip
correct so you're gonna pick the one out
to live in flip into that
uh hold an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and everything
else goes into your down payment
to minimize the amount of debt you have
in the one you're going to stay in
15-year fixed where the payment's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
and you have no other debt right um i
actually we have a
jeep we have about 15 000 on it that i
have
okay you need to pay that off probably
go and pay that off today
okay that'll leave you 10 000 in your
account
and you're debt free except the house
put the house up for sale then buy your
other property when this one sells and
roll everything beyond three to six
months of expenses
into this property and don't take on a
payment that's more than a fourth of
your take-home pay
and then you're you're set man you're on
the track
to go ahead and start your long-term
investing fifteen percent of your income
baby step four going into your investing
and start your kids college fund for
that baby and then any other money you
can scrape together do
you know let's get this house paid off
long term what i would be doing if i'm
in your shoes because you've obviously
had some success at this
is i'm going to uh not only get your
home paid off and once it's paid off i'm
going to build up a house fund
to do flips with in cash from this point
forward but that's probably
seven to ten years from today that's
what my guess would be
but i did that for a long time it's a
fun business uh only i was stupid i did
it with debt
um and that's one of the reasons i went
broke so i wouldn't want you to continue
doing that
but um i i think you're you know you've
had you've had a good run here let's use
it to settle down the family get
everything paid off and then you can go
back to doing the business cash later
what do you think
i absolutely agree because as a roofer
maybe he has designs to be
you know his own boss one day certainly
as a roofer he's got all these
connections
i think take a deep breath like you said
and before you know it time flies the
child's older maybe number two's along
and you're not having to live
in them to be able to flip it which is
what you're recommending i think it's a
great decision gives him a lot of
options yeah
so i think this is one of those cases
where your wife is right
and it's wise to listen to her yes happy
wife happy life it's been said
and i can attest to that i think jeff
allen our friend the comedian yes he did
that's right he called her buttercup i
believe oh i'm not even gonna talk about
this
okay all right carl's in destin florida
hey carl
welcome to the ramsay show what's up
gentlemen thanks for taking my call
i have a unique situation here um i'm
64.
my wife is 65. we have uh
three properties two are rentals um
we have no mortgages no car payments no
anything good for you
all the rams in the world wait a couple
products
many years ago paying off the mortgage
whatever i got in a rental i put
directly on the mortgage directly on the
mortgage
we also have 401ks my question is at
this age
should i continue to buy properties and
invest or just leave the money sit in
the bank or what should i do
what do you want to do i don't know
i feel like i should be productive and
continue making money
okay you're only 64. i'm 60 i'm not
signing up for death right now
so yeah what does productive mean to you
and i i'm asking this question carl not
from productive with your investments
because you've been very very smart
financially
i mean at 64 the fact that you're free
and can do anything
realistically does productivity mean to
you
uh to me it means just you know being a
wage earner i'm retired now i'm not
earning
um any major wages you know you know in
a two three hundred
thousand dollar field but um i i just
really not sure
i i so your net worth is it sounds like
to me your net worth's over 2 million
approximately yeah good guess almost
like i've done this before
okay so the uh uh way to go
beautiful job so now you've landed on
the
island of paradise now what do we do so
if i'm you number one yes i'm going to
continue to invest in real estate and
i'm going to pay cash for whatever i buy
as i go we're not going back into debt
but i think you have some fun with that
i think you've had a good run with
property you like
property um you know if you told me you
hate being a landlord then probably
that's not the plan that's not the
definition of productivity as being in
real estate
but it's something that's at your
fingertips that you already have some
knowledge of
you feel good about but no we're not
signing up for coasting into retire
or coasting into death at 64. we're
going to sign up for
continuing to plow the field the second
thing i'll challenge you on is a ken
coleman challenge
and that is why don't you back up and
whiteboard this thing for a minute and
go
crap if i could do anything i wanted to
do with the next 15 to 20 years
what would i do yeah because you know
colonel sanders never fried any chicken
until he was 64. that's right
oh and that just happens to be carl's
age as i recall
here so carl that's what i listen you
don't need to be a wage earner anymore
what work do you want to do let me put
it this way what contribution would you
like to give as dave just said over the
next five
ten years you want fried chicken all
over the world with your face on it i
don't know
i doubt that but you know you know what
what is the thing man what's the thing
you're truly at a place where you can do
that this is where most people want to
end up
yeah absolutely well done sir yeah so
proud of you
very very cool mitch is in kansas city
mitch is
how can we help sir hey dave uh
thanks for taking my call sure um i am
28 i'm single i have a daughter who
lives with her mother
um i'm currently renting i make about
50k a year
growth i'm on baby step two and my um
the question is my credit karma shows
that i have about eight accounts and
collections
with around twenty four hundred dollars
owed which is relatively easy to take
care of
i guess um and i can pay that off within
three to four months or so
the problem is that i have um you know
i'm 100
positive that credit card isn't showing
me my entire debt or collections list
um how do i find that list and who
should i contact
about the correct or most efficient way
to get them removed or
entirely you know well uh to start with
credit karma's crap
okay let's just establish that so it's
it's a it's a bait and switch thing to
get you signed
up for more debt is it's just a mess
so what instead what i would do is let's
go to all three
of the major credit bureaus directly and
pull a copy of your credit bureau report
you can get a lot more detail that way
of exactly what is owed
and who last reported to you so these
are old enough debts that they've
probably been sold off to someone else
is what you're thinking
yeah yeah okay so you need to dig
through that and start contacting them
and it's a bit of a treasure
hunt because they start selling this bad
debt from place to place to place to
place how old are these debts how long
since you paid on them
a lot of them are five years or some of
them are three but
you know yeah you've got a past okay
sure that you've grown up
through okay so yeah get in touch with
them be sure you get in
writing what you're agreeing to pay them
which might be the original balance that
they've marked up seven-fold by now
but get it in writing and do not give
them electronic access to your checking
account but just go to the three major
credit bureau reporting
companies experian transunion and
equifax
and you can pull out what you need there
directly and you'll get much
higher quality of information because
they're not trying to bait and switch
you
as much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free
stage deshayne is with us hi deshane how
are you
hi welcome where do you live san antonio
texas
very cool and all the way to nashville
to do a debt free scream
yes how much have you paid off 95 000
in 15 months and your range of income
during that time
135 000 what do you do for a living
um i work in project management at usaa
oh good for you
wow and you're obviously great at it
congratulations thank you
very well done what kind of debt was the
95 000
um i had majority of it was credit cards
i had a car loan um i had student loans
and then
i had some taxes that i needed to pay
for you were just kind of normal
yes a little bit of everything just
bumping along
everything seems normal all the money
comes in all the money goes out what
happened what changed everything
um well i was married for
um almost 20 years and i went through a
divorce
and during my divorce i inherited all
that debt
how did you get it all i just wanted to
be done with my marriage
i was willing worth anything to get rid
of him that kind of guy yeah
okay we're better now but yes
yes now that he lives miles away
all right so you take on 95 000 worth of
mess
on your own to clean it up coming out of
a divorce yes that had to be scary
super scary we were in collections i had
no idea where to start
i was in such an emotional mess yeah
um definitely financial mess and
a lot of the debt that we incurred in
our marriage from a credit card
perspective that was all me
um and so i went to church
i attended this program and that's where
i met the scullys
and that program helped me to reset
really my heart and my mind and
once i was done with that i had the
courage to finally tackle my debt
instead of avoiding it and just making
minimum payments and barely making ends
meet
and so maddie had posted that they were
going to start offering fpu and i
thought
okay i've got to do this i need to make
this commitment for myself i need to get
myself out of this mess
and my very first class
they shared their story and it was your
story and it was my story
yeah um but theirs gave me hope
yeah so much hope in that
i didn't have a relationship with my
kids i definitely did not have a
relationship with my ex-husband
and i just wanted to finally have peace
in my life and
they gave me the big picture view that
this wasn't just a budgeting class
this wasn't just you know how to spend
your money it was inviting god into your
finances and
letting him lead the way so i mean i
i think after like class two i had so
much hope and i had so much drive i was
like okay i'll sell everything
i will get a roommate i will take on a
second job i will move out of my
apartment when my lease is up move in
with family and that's exactly what i
did oh my god
they really set me on fire and maddie
and scully they were like
my biggest cheerleaders there'd be days
where i'm like okay i don't know what to
do or hey i'm selling this and
it's all these little things that really
just helped me to just keep moving
forward
even when i felt like i don't know if
this is working but
i'm getting closer so wow so let me uh
backtrack just a little bit
before you went to fpu you went to a
class
a different class not ours that the
church was holding on how to just
put your life together yes it's called
peel the onion and it they offered at
city church
okay and it's just all about you getting
whole
foods and then you were whole enough at
that point so that when you stepped into
fpu
you're like game on yes okay because you
were you were you were
uh uh beat up beaten down
needed some recovery just to be able to
have the the courage and the strength to
fight the debt
absolutely yeah that's very powerful
that's a great one-two punch
and also for our listening audience that
don't know maddie and scully are of
course rock stars around here
they've held uh some almost 40 financial
peace university classes
uh maddie's story's not dissimilar to
yours except they were able to stay
married
and uh she had run up debt and she's
told that story on our videos many times
and powerful couple
and they've led thousands of families
like they have to shane
uh this way and they've made the trip
with her to uh to be here
uh for the debt free scream because
they're so proud of her so
uh they're they're friends of ours close
friends of all of ours here at ramsey
and um
they're like rockstar financial peace
university coordinators so that's what
she's referring to
and for those of you on youtube she's
pointing off to her right but they're
sitting over there there's a shot okay
we get
get them over there okay cool and uh so
to shane well done thank you
so when was the divorce
the divorce was january of 2018 that's
when our divorce is final
okay so three years
ago your life was so freaking different
than where it is today how old are you
i'm 43.
so i'm debt-free and 43. i like it i
like it i like it
yeah she's got a slogan she's got a
slogan that's it yep
well but the thing is i mean the last
three years have been
really really really tough yes uh and a
portion of those years have been hell
and now there's nothing but just
sunshine because you took such control
of every element of your life
money being actually the last step that
you did
you got your spiritual life in order
your emotional and relational life and
order and all the other things
and then step through this process i'm
so proud of you you are an absolute rock
star kiddo
thank you it's absolutely amazing you
know duchenne i want to i want to have
you i'm going to ask you a question
you can talk to our audience because
you've already talked about maddie and
scully and what they meant to you but i
want you to talk about the fact you were
very alone
relationally and financially and
you had the fpu class that community i
want you to speak to the importance of
having community because even though you
had them early on
the fact of the matter is when you pay
off 95 000 in 15 months there's some
serious serious
dark days because you're hustling what
does community do for this process why
is it so important
it helped me have accountability um
people were asking
questions having conversations in class
and
you know in our in our facebook page
that i hadn't even thought about so
i think there was a time where scully
had asked a question about
what would you do if you were debt free
and that's something that i had
never ever envisioned in my life because
i have
just known debt forever and
um that was one of the biggest things
where i realized like
if you know i shared previously that
there was a scripture that came to my
heart which was
um where there is no vision that people
perish
and i had no vision for my finances i
had no
vision um with what to do with my life
and i just let chaos lead me
and being able to have people that were
focused that had goals
i could finally see that as an example
in my life and so that helped me out
tremendously
i just went to church yes sir yes amen
and breach it girl
wow so powerful so powerful
all right so now you're an expert what's
the key to getting out of debt
consistency and discipline and
accountability i mean there's a lot
there's a lot that i can focus on but
there were days where i was like i don't
know that i can continue to do this i
used to have family members tell me
well that's not important you can
continue to be in debt you know
debt is what everybody does and that
just wasn't for me
um and when i was accountable to my
finances
knowing that this is the lord's money
knowing that i needed to be a good
steward of that money that helped me
focus so much and everything else that
came with it the financial immense with
my ex-husband the new relationship that
i had with my kids
that was way more important than the
things that i was surrounding
myself with in my life you're powerful
you are a powerful woman that's amazing
well done
very well done well we've got a copy of
rachel cruz's latest new york times
bestseller
know yourself know your money which will
be a bit poignant for you
that's very fun it's uh it's a beautiful
text for the situation that you're in
today i'm so proud of you
all of us at ramsey are and i know
maddie and scully are they're over
they're both crying like little girls
[Laughter]
scully's a bigger crier than maddie is
he's like me he cries at applebee's
commercials so
uh but well done well done so well done
all right here it is deshane 95
000 paid off in 15 months making 135
and she redeemed her whole life yes in
the process count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
this is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
wow wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones a triple eight eight
two five
five two two five
our team created and ken created a six
easy to use resume
templates that'll help you get noticed
they're only nine bucks 99 999
you get six customizable resume
templates instructions for building a
resume
plus the 10 do's and don'ts of job
applications one of our callers earlier
this hour said he got a job because
of ken's resume or at least had a part
in it anyway
if you want to learn more about those
templates text to the word resume two
three three
seven eight nine resume to thirty three
seven
eighty nine our question of the day
comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal
today's question comes from kevin in
california he asked i am an electrician
making seventy thousand dollars a year
and my wife and i are in baby step two
with everything going on in california
many businesses are moving to utah
and that state has an electrician's
shortage builders are throwing money at
trade workers for temporary employment
until each
project is done should i leave my
current stable job
to search for money and risk not having
a job a year from now the company i work
for has made it known that if you leave
to find money you won't be rehired
in this situation because you're in baby
step two kevin
i don't like you leaving the current
stable job
for project employment i just don't like
that at all i think if you can move to
utah
or any other state where you can get a
full-time
and not a project-based electrician job
i'd be fine with that but in baby step
two
we want you to walk the baby steps out
get that three to six
three or six month emergency fund in
place in baby step three
and get going in baby step four and get
going and then we we step
into a better job opportunity we don't
jump and potentially hurt yourself
financially
so if you could go and make double the
money in utah
i would consider going but only if you
move there and make that your new job
yeah
that is the the long-term play yeah and
you know
it can be in the electrician world that
you could go from project to project
but there's got to be plenty of work
there and a bunch more money and it's a
permanent move it's not i'm just going
to run over to the strange land of utah
make some money and
come back that's right no i mean not
that utah's stranger i'm just saying
like people used to do that with dubai
or stuff or they would do that
uh you know uh people coming out of the
military would go back as civilians and
do military
type work on a civilian contract uh in
afghanistan or whatever and make a bunch
of money for short period of time
uh and then come back but they were
unemployed yeah and so uh but
yeah the question is where do you want
to live
and then let's build a life there
that's the thing that's right and you
could take a vacation take some vacation
days go make some connections really
walk around meet some people in that
field and feel get a feel for what
that's going to look like but i just
don't like that dave a little too risky
trying to do that i'm going to jump here
for the short term absolutely
absolutely well done very very well done
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five thomas is in
houston
hey thomas welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi dave thanks for for having me sure
what's up
the question i have is essentially i
feel like
i need to generate more income uh
likely by starting a business or
something but i'm not sure
if it's wise uh given my situation
um i'm 41 years old
i am uh finalizing
a divorce about a 13-year marriage
marriage was pretty bad and i
stuck in it wait longer than i should
have
and um but we you know we have a
an agreement you know a mediation
agreement that the judge just has to
sign signs
i know what uh what my responsibilities
are going forward
and essentially i have
a 420 000 mortgage
a i have 96 000 in student loans
i also have about 8 000 in credit card
debt which is
it's primarily attorney fees and
um i make about 125 000 a year
what's the house worth
less than i mean it's like 400 because
the market here is
is uh i did uh
and then last you know a year or so i
don't know if it's
because of cohort or what like yeah the
market is taking a dip here
really in houston texas i thought it was
quite hot
uh well i don't know are you in a bad
neighborhood
no you're in a 400 000 house you're not
in a bad neighborhood
yeah i mean that's that's what i thought
when i i bought this house
uh yeah almost two years ago but there's
nobody there but you after the divorce
right
excuse me i'm sorry you're the only one
living in the 400 000 house by yourself
after the divorce right
um no so so we're going to share the
kids uh 50 50.
i have i have so i have three kids well
there's
technically two kids in in the marriage
i have custody
of uh of an older of
the oldest child from the previous
relationship but so i have so heat so
one child is staying with me 100
and or near 100 i should say and then
the teachers and in the marriage how old
are these three kids
13 10 and seven okay what's your
question
so i mean it's just
the whole thing is very discouraging
sure
when i when i put my details and i went
on your website to
use the student loan payoff calculator
and
you know it seems like it's like upwards
of 10 years no
no no no no not even close not even
close what what
what what um what do you do for a living
i'm in engineering and operations for
medical devices
okay and how old did you say you were
i'm 41.
okay thomas sharon and i when we were 28
went through losing everything and we
were bankrupt and had to start
completely over and it crushed us
emotionally mentally spiritually
financially everything we were just
powder
and i hear that pain
of being at the worst moment in your
entire life so far in your voice am i
missing something
uh i don't know i don't think you are
yeah
so would it be fair to say and this is
not name calling because it's where i
was
would it be fair to say you have less
confidence today than you norm than
than the normal thomas has
i absolutely sure i mean cuz that makes
you like a human
by the way okay with the hell you've
been through and you're looking at this
pile of debt and you're looking at these
three teenagers or quasi teenagers
and you're looking at a 400 000 house
and you're looking at the end of
a mess and the sun has not come out
the next morning after the mess yet and
you're still in the dark of night that's
what i
hear in your spirit when i'm talking to
you
and so that makes it really easy for me
to accurately say
dude you're a whole lot better than you
freaking feel right now
yes yeah so here's what we're gonna do
okay
i can see print mathematically how we
can get you out of this probably gonna
sell the house just for the fun of it
it's just a stupid house
you can get a place to rent for a little
while with these kids let's get this
mess cleaned up
because that's a big old freaking house
for you to carry by yourself
with this amount of debt with this
income and so i'm probably going to step
down in monthly payment for housing and
get rid of this thing go get you another
one it's just a house kids are going to
survive the house they're going to
survive the divorce
they're going to be okay it's not going
to screw up their entire lives based on
where they live
and we're going to put you into ramsey
plus with financial peace university and
show you step by step exactly
with coaches at your fingertips and
groups that you can plug into
exactly how you're going to do this
because i can see if you dump that house
and get on a tight budget and get these
teenagers fired up about the next phase
of our life
and you start selling so much stuff they
think they're next and you
even think about some extra income and
what you can do to scratch around and do
that because you're a very bright guy
you just had the you just had a butt
weapon man yeah and it's just hard
it just hurts and i get it i've been
there i know how it feels
and i i think you can turn this
completely
around so you hang on kelly will pick up
i'm gonna put you in that
uh as our guest ken did did you hear
something
yeah i heard him say that should i make
more income the answer is yes
and i think when you got the split time
with the kids you're working when you're
not with the kids you're working i would
be careful he mentioned should i start a
business
we didn't have time to unpack that to be
very cautious about starting a business
right now
let's go work and make some money and
get gazelle intense
business is too hard to do at the bottom
of your emotions
yeah you need to really have your
muscles built to start businesses
and we got to get those rebuilt right
now they're somewhat atrophied from this
long fight he's been through
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality
expert on careers and you getting your
next job is my co-host today
so we'll talk about your careers we'll
talk about your life we'll talk about
your money all right in front of you
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
mike is with us in new york city to
start off this hour hey mike how are you
i'm doing well dave and yourself better
than i deserve sir how can i help
all right so uh essentially uh i had a
qu
you know a couple questions uh i i
graduated
from college here on may of 20 um a
pandemic grad didn't get to have
graduation but
i think they mailed me the diploma so i
guess that counts
um so i racked up uh
about 146 000 undergrads um
23 of that was public the rest was
private
um it gave me anxiety in college you
know i got out i was
fortunate enough to get a job uh out of
school
um i've refinanced the private one twice
down from about seven percent to like
point three eight so that's great good
what's your degree in uh finance
um so i work in financial services
um so i had for the last nine months uh
so i i live at home uh so
uh luckily i was uh you know fortunate
enough to discover your program
uh as a young person with a lot of debt
and fresh out of school
um you know i got you know like i said i
got a job and
i make about post tax about 3 500 a
month
uh of that i'll put 14.50
bi-weekly towards the debt so
about 2 900 a month and then they give
me a little bit about two grand a year
so
it's about four over three thousand a
month i pay back uh so like in nine
months i've paid off
by 32 it sounded like 114 so i probably
paid off like 32 000. so
good for you that's yeah that's good
that's good so
my question for you essentially is a
couple things
um you know i don't want to live at home
like for a long time i have a long
distance girlfriend who's four hours
away
um and i'd like to be closer here at
some point
my question to you and something i
wrangle with right i have a good
situation here i'm able to shovel a lot
of money
um but i also feel like if i move out i
i elongate my timeline because i'm not
paying rent i i am fortunate
enough to have that so i wrestle with
like
do i stay at home am i stumping my
personal growth
should i go and chase like i went to
school down south
i'd love to live down south but like
also that encouraged rent and other
expenses and
things like that so i'm just torn like
whether to stay at home on 25 26 at the
blistering pace
where's the girlfriend she lives in dc
okay is that where you're talking about
going is that down
south for you no no no no i'd like to go
to uh like a southern city like uh
charlotte charleston uh nashville
something like that charlotte charlotte
and nashville are both
really strong financial centers so uh
you don't make a lot of money um
i'm kind of surprised uh but i mean are
you on some kind of quick upward track
with your career
yeah i mean i you know i
hopefully i i expect to be promoted in
the next like
three to six months yeah what what
exactly are you doing
um essentially it's it's uh basically a
financial advisor
uh training program so get licensed you
know oh okay so you're
you're running on a stipend until you
get a client base built
yeah essentially so like uh you know
it's more of like an assistant
you know to the person yeah and once you
you know gets it get some uh
you know traction then you start talking
hey mike what's your payoff date
right now if you stay at home if i stay
at home
with about a hundred so quick matt say i
always like trust
that you know was it hoping for the best
but expecting the worst like i
if i just stayed at this salary right
yeah it would be
and i paid bi-weekly it's about 40 grand
a year
so it's about two and a half years if i
pay bi-weekly and
i'm i can confidently say that i'm like
trying to do it in two years like
yeah but mike mike you're over analyzing
this man
the bottom line is you got to weigh the
two and a half years if you stay home
stay where you are and you know your
income's going to go up so you've done
kind of your least
amount of income scenario yeah so if you
move
south or dc whatever that looks like you
start making more money you just got to
start running the numbers and
really truly look at how much more would
it elongate using your work
it won't i don't think it's very much at
all i don't think it's much at all
because
and so here's what amounts to do i put
my entire life on hold for two and a
half years
including uh stepping out as an adult
and having my own place
or do i step into some of these things
like a new position and you start
shopping for that use ken coleman's
materials and land that
in the city that you want to be in um
and making even more or making or the
chance to make the same but at a lower
cost of living than new york city
and uh the new york city market whatever
it is and so
because charlotte is less expensive than
new york city or the area around new
york city for sure
or nashville would be or dallas would be
so yeah i think you got to make these
moves um
and and the truth is that what will
happen
inside of your soul will cause you to
make more money because you're living
your life man uh
and um and instead of like you know i'm
just i'm i'm
you know you're you're you are you're
getting caught up in
uh addition type math rather than
multiplication type math
yeah it's really well said and so i i
you know
because i think when you you know engage
this relationship with this lady
you uh engage your dreams
uh you are on your own you're out there
leaving the cave kill something drag it
home
you're going to blossom in ways you're
not going to blossom in your other
scenario that are going to
affect your income and so the net net is
probably
not any elongation but even if it is so
what do it anyway yeah we're talking
about a small amount of time as young as
you are here's the other thing you're
not married you got the long-distance
girlfriend work a second job
yeah knock the baby steps i mean get
after it man and
i think that two and a half years can
shrink substantially if you get after it
yeah the safe course is seldom the best
course
yes i say that all the time we have a
world dave that
we've been trained to do the safe
smart decision and i got a bunch of
adults who call the ken coleman show
every day that did safe and smart and
they're miserable at 35 and 45 and what
i mean by that to explain that to you
folks is that
we get taught that we got to go to the
safe college get the safe major
to get a safe job if you're not more
attractive to this young lady when
you're out there on your own in the wild
swinging
you're certainly more attractive to her
dad
that is great perspective there i didn't
see that but that's a very good point
that's a really good point you know so
you come in and sit down at my table as
for my daughter's hand and bless
in marriage yeah and you're in your
mama's basement or you're out there
swinging and you're scared to death and
you're fighting and you're scratching
and you're clawing
it's a different conversation bubba that
might be two out of three strikes with
dave ramsey i know uh
and you could feel it in his voice he
was kind of looking for permission for
us to be okay
he was already going we just need to
kick him the rest way out of the nest
hey baby fly his mama's gonna be so mad
at me yes
this is the dave ramsey oh no it's not
it's the ramsay show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
if you feel like you've tried everything
when it comes to money
but you can't seem to get traction i
know the feeling
a lot of people do maybe you tried
budgeting but you couldn't figure it out
or you got big money goals and you're
not sure how to reach them
you may need a financial coach someone
who can help you understand
what's holding you back develop a custom
plan to reach your goals and we've got a
network
of financial coaches all across the
country who are ready to work with you
they're called ramsey
preferred coaches these financial
coaches are trained the ramsey way not
only will they guide you with a personal
plan
they'll help you form the right habits
to win with money
now let us help you find the right coach
for you we'll connect you with the top
three coaches in
your area and you get to choose which
one you want to work with
it's time to make progress with your
finances stop wanting
to reach your money goals and start
doing it to get started text
coach me two three three seven eight
nine
text coach me all one word
233 789 grace is with us in kansas city
she's in northland christian high
school's
personal finance class with our
curriculum hey guys how are you class
oh he's saying hi to class okay hold on
i'm not on speakerphone oh that's okay
that's okay
i love it all right miss grace how can
we help
all right so we've been watching your
content in our class
for quite a bit and we thought it would
be fun to call you so
our little question we came up with was
if
your spouse is in a pretty financially
like
pretty unstable situation and you're not
what's like
a good plan what's a good place to start
to handle that
okay so that's a weird question for
people in high school but that's okay
yeah i still like it it's a good
question um the
uh well to start with what we would
teach people to do is to get on the same
page
with each other so that one of you is
not carrying the other one and one of
you is not holding the other one back
in other words there's not her money and
his money it's our
money and so whatever money comes in we
are going to manage it together and we
are going to agree on a plan we both
have a vote
on where that money is going to go and
we are going to stick to the plan
that we agreed to and suddenly the one
that is struggling with stability has
the other one for accountability
and the one that was trying to drag
along the one who was unstable
is no longer doing that because they now
have a willing participant
helping them uh you know and working
together
uh and so for instance sometimes what
happens is
not sometimes almost always what happens
is one is more of a spender
than the other uh i'm the bigger spender
at my house my wife's more of a natural
saver
and so it did our marriage a lot of good
30 years ago
for us to be on the same page and be in
agreement on any spending that was going
to occur before it occurred
so i don't buy things without my wife
knowing it ahead of time and without us
being in agreement
on the purchase and she doesn't buy
things without me knowing it so we're on
the same page and i know ken you and
stacey do the same thing
absolutely and the key uh phrase here
that dave just shared is willing
participant
those two things we get these calls a
lot on the ramsay show we've
counseled and coached a lot of couples
where we'll have a caller will call in
and say
hey dave i'm i'm on i'm using your steps
but my spouse isn't how do i get
this willing participant piece is really
huge that getting on the same page about
finances
uh is a relationship issue and many
times you've got to get healthy and get
that relationship where it needs to be
to where
both people are seeing this desired
future and seeing how
handling your money god's ways uh is the
way to do it and so
that is always key you know you've got
to be on the same page and sometimes
relationally you gotta handle that first
to be able to then take care of
the money stuff yeah so grace since i've
got the northern north
northland christian high school
curriculum finance
class the whole finance class from the
foundations and personal finance captive
let's kind of go let's turn the question
a little bit and take it all the way
more make it more relevant for you guys
uh because the vast majority of you are
not married i suppose
okay and so uh what it amounts to is
this we know
statistically from doing this for
decades that the number one cause of
divorce in north america today
is money fights and money problems
we know the number one thing couples
fight about which of course then leads
to divorce oftentimes
is money fights and money problems so if
we know that this is the number one
enemy of your future marriage
when you are dating this is the number
one thing you're gonna make sure you're
on the same page on before you become
spouses ding ding ding there so you so
you know if you cannot
if if you know you're getting ready to
marry
you ladies are getting ready to marry a
guy who just doesn't like to work much
in other words he's a lazy hound dog
okay and he's not he's always going to
struggle but he's an artist
and he's fun and he's he's a bad boy or
whatever it is that you think he's
attractive ha ha
right but at the end of the day you know
when you're 30 you're still going to be
supporting this bozo
this is this guy's not marriage material
guys if you're dating a girl and she's a
freaking princess and she thinks the
whole world revolves around her
and she can spend whatever she wants to
spend like she's in congress because her
daddy always gave her more money than
she had since
and he had since and you think you can
keep up with that with your income
starting a new household you're screwed
man you're not going to
you're never going to make that little
princess happy and she's always going to
make you broke
so if you can't get on the same page
while you're dating
moving towards marriage about money that
is the ultimate reason to not
get married to not continue the
relationship
yep i think it's absolutely right dave i
would tell josie i would tell chase and
ty the same thing
it ought to be non-negotiable if this is
what you believe about money what we
teach
and you really believe it then it has to
be
uh it's a foundational issue before you
even think about marriage yeah because
it's
it can it be done have we seen marriages
change after the fact yes
but why why not avoid the pain yeah
avoid the pain i think that's great
advice
just so yeah again you don't worry about
this in high school
but later on when you're entering more
serious relationships that are going to
lead to marriage
do not go forward with those if you're
not
paired on this issue if you can't get
agreement that this is how we're going
to live our life
we're not going to spend like we're in
congress we're not going to buy cars we
can't afford
and unless we can pay cash for them
we're not going to we're always going to
have money saved
we're going to live on a plan we're both
going to be in agreement we're going to
combine our finances
these are these are things that indicate
that you're working together
going forward you will save yourself
young people an amazing amount of
heartache
if you don't try to train your spouse
after marriage
that's true and here's the other thing
don't just talk to him about it and
and settle for the yeah yeah i'm fine
with that if you're gonna get serious
now we're talking about down the road as
dave's talking about if you're gonna get
serious
before you say yes or you ask uh
look at their finances get them to show
you again somebody's got something to
hide
won't show you yeah i'm just telling you
that somebody who's a mess right now and
saying
all the things but their actual current
personal finances are a mess
that's a red flag i mean i got to tell
you i don't mind i don't
mind if they're in a mess i don't even
mind if they're in debt as long as
they're working their tail off to get a
straightened out that's correct
that they're actually acting on it not
giving you we are not saying don't marry
someone with that
no we're not saying we're saying don't
marry someone loves dad
if you hate debt because you're gonna
hate each other yeah before it's over
it's not gonna work and so you know you
need to be on the same page with that
and the marriage folks in the marriage
field and dr john deloney confirms this
that there's tons of research that backs
up
the other three areas by the way while
we're in this uh
that you need to be in agreement on uh
prior to marriage are religion
kids whether i have them how many and
how to treat them
and how to deal with the crazy people in
your family
the in-laws and there are crazy people
in your family and if you don't think
there's crazy people in your family that
means
it's you because everyone has crazy
people
somewhere in their family and so there
you go
yeah you need to be in agreement on you
know boundaries kids
religion and money yeah and if you can
lay those things in place
as a healthy dating relationship your
statistical chance of that marriage
working out
is very very high it's true and of it
being high quality marriage
yeah don't discount it folks i'm telling
you dave's right on this i mean you
gotta know what's non-negotiable yeah
how does life work you know
i i don't believe there's a god i hate
god i'm mad at god
i'm out of people who think there's a
god and the other one is
i worship jesus 24 7. this ain't going
to work out boys and girls
missionary dating doesn't work i'm sorry
sorry it's just the real world and you
can get mad and tweet about me i don't
look on twitter anyway so just
have at it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
ken coleman ramsay personality is my
co-host today
johnny and holly are with us from camp
lejeune north carolina
says on my screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you well done how much have you
paid off
um around 59 000 59
000 bucks how long did this take 15
months
15 months and your range of income
during that time
108. okay
cool so camp lejeune are you in the
military
yes sir thank you for your service what
do you do
i do uh supply chain management ah
very nice great career field good for
you
good fun fun fun all right what kind of
debt was this 59
000 bucks well let's just say
um mainly credit cards um we owed a
little bit like 2500 on one of our cars
um and then some to student loans but it
was mainly a shopping problem on my end
whoa yeah i'm gonna come right out with
it
i'm just gonna start with this huh all
right just dive right in here so
tell me what happened well
um i just remember one evening looking
over at my husband
we have a really good marriage we're
really good fit
but i just looked over at him and it was
the same scene i'd seen at the end of
the month every month just his head in
his hands looking over our finances
shaking his head like
how are we you know living month to
month on this income
[Music]
and i really thought it was going to be
the end of our marriage
yeah eventually now i mean we were still
in a place but eventually would have
led to our demise yeah absolutely
yeah wow so what'd you do
hey johnny we got to fix this and he
went no kidding
yeah so um i had read uh your book the
totem total money makeover
in 2015 i was kind of doing
davish but then holly got him bored
and we set a budget and we stick with
the budget
and that helped a lot yeah that's
everything right there
okay so once you decide holly says she's
going to go along with it and then you
decide we're going to do the whole
program
boom you start getting traction right
yes
15 months i'm looking at this pink sheet
with all these
names on here that i don't like wells
fargo chase
mbna navient these are good people to
have out of your life aren't they
absolutely yeah and i like the big lines
drawn through them on this
showing on the youtube channel here i'm
seeing it that is my that was my
favorite part
johnny got to press submit on all the
online stuff i just like to cross off
the desk as we went that's that on a
refrigerator for the whole world to see
anybody that came in our house that was
up on display we had no shame at that
point
yeah it's just the only shame is if it
stays there we're getting rid of it
yeah and that's game on game on which
one of those when you paid them off you
said i hate you people i'm so glad
you're gone
i'll let johnny answer that i would say
it was the student loans dave um
being the military uh ta pay for my
tuition
but i still got student loans somehow
and it was a
blessing to get you know these student
loans out of my life
amen amen well congratulations i'm so
proud of you guys
so well done how old are you two 36
okay okay so in the last 15 months
holly you've reshaped your whole brain
around money
and you guys have joined into your
marriage in a completely different way
y'all talk about that for a minute
well i would just say um we both worked
um i was working up until recently we're
about to move here so um
i would just check our bank account you
know and if like i don't know i had a
set number if there were 700
in there was like okay i can still shop
once it got under 700 i just asked
johnny like hey how are we doing for
money
um and then once we started with this
dave ramsey i knew every single bill
coming out
i actually had some things auto paid on
my credit card that i didn't even know i
had been paying for for the last two
years that was
eye-opening wow what was that
sorry what what was that what was the
two auto things i had like this karaoke
app that i was paying for
oh my god it was like 25 a month that i
had signed up when we got our daughters
a karaoke machine
25 a month for unused karaoke
yes that's the ultimate of insults
yes oh man i love it
congratulations you guys it's a great
story i'm so proud of y'all
there's a there's a sense here that that
not only has your marriage been impacted
but there that you did some growing up
and
uh you just like stepped into a whole
other level of adulthood do you feel
that way
absolutely and we've been very um
forward with sharing our story we've
always put our numbers out there
um johnny will tell everyone that stands
still in front of him for more than
three seconds about you and how you've
changed his life
um so you know if you're around johnny
hang you you've heard about his
financial wins and he wants everybody he
comes in contact with to win too
so um well thank you johnny and thank
you again for your service it's pretty
cool story ken
it really is uh when we looked at that
list on the youtube channel we got to
see
the debt snowball right there on your
sheet of paper uh that's some serious
payments that you guys
paid off uh in 15 months that's getting
with it i'd love to hear some of the
sacrifices
what did gazelle intense actually look
like in your home
well a lot of it oh
goodness eating out no restaurants
that was huge actually keeping track of
our food budget
that was another really big one
and just you know when we made our plan
every month we stuck to it you know
every dollar app was amazing for helping
keep us on track we didn't do cash we
did everything
with our debit card and using every
dollar app
wow so this is a situation where you had
you didn't get a
you didn't get any more income the
income didn't increase you just really
budgeted it made it work yes
yes yes that's inspiring you know johnny
being in the military i was working
for a non-profit that i absolutely loved
i loved my job
and neither one of us wanted to take you
know more time away from our kids
to do other you know other side hustles
or anything like that so it was just
mainly just
behavior changes so the military moving
you now you said you're getting ready to
move again
yeah yes you know where you're going yet
we're going to boston
ah okay another another adventure
well well done you guys i'm so proud of
you we got a copy of rachel cruz's book
for you
uh love you or no i try to say it here
know yourself know your money absolutely
as if i didn't write the forward okay so
that's it and so
uh you you hang on we'll have kelly pick
up and get that to you if she hadn't
already
will take good care of you and i know
you guys were scheduled to be over here
and we had the uh
the nash blizzard uh event over here and
you got snowed out on that uh and
sorry that happened but we're glad we
got you on the phone to do your debt
free scream you guys are a great
inspiration well done
thank you all right it's johnny and
holly in camp lejeune north carolina 59
000 paid off in 15 months
making 108 000 a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
well done oh that's amazing
beautifully done beautifully done that's
an inspiring thing right there
for a lot of you spouses out there
listening to this right now
if you are the holly in that
relationship
whether you're the husband or the wife
but you're the one that your spouse does
the money
and you've looked over like she looked
over and saw johnny's head in his hands
so many times shaking his head knowing i
don't know how we're going to do this
what the gift she gave herself
the gift she gave him the gift she gave
to her kids future
when she looked over and saw that and
said i value this family
and its future more than i do my selfish
right to spend
like i'm in congress i'm gonna work with
my husband my wife and get this stuff
done
that gift when she raised her chin and
did that she stepped into a whole
different level of emotional maturity
spiritual maturity uh than she had ever
seen before and it's
it's blessed her family no question you
know it's just another reminder that
you do what you have to do so you can do
what you want to do and sometimes we got
to say no to the want
and do the right thing and in this case
it was her relationship and
not just the financial piece of it but
just the legacy you think of though you
know we saw the picture of those two
little beautiful girls oh
i mean they're aware of all this you
know these kids you know rachel has said
anything feel the tension in the room
more is caught and taught and they saw a
transformation go on
those kids are picking that stuff up so
great legacy great legacy
for those two it's a wonderful story of
transformation you see what happens is
it's not really about the money
no about the person in your mirror and
it transforms
you you are changing and then guess what
magically the money changes go figure
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
taxes everybody's got to do them
everybody hates them
except for weird people nobody wants to
screw with this but
with ramsey smart text you finally have
an easy
money smart way to file online the other
software out there
it's not what it's cracked up to be it
is free you say
yeah no turbotax is not free for the
vast majority of people who use it they
sign you up and then they ratchet up the
price and suddenly free turns into
50 or 60 or 120 dollars and of course
they're going to jack you around and try
to get you in 63 different credit cards
while they're at it
we don't do any of that the cost to file
a federal tax return with ramsey smart
tax is crystal clear it's 17
or 37 depending on the level of support
you need or want
plus 32 if you have to file state taxes
and some folks don't like in tennessee
we don't have state tax
income tax but listen it's uh it's not
just about the cost our software and our
support will go toe-to-toe with turbo
tax any day of the week
and we'll never leverage your financial
situation to sell your credit cards
or to sell you ridiculous loans we're
not going to peddle stuff at you that's
going to hurt your finances
sign up for smart tax for free take a
look around the software
you won't pay a thing until you're
confident that you got your taxes right
and you're ready to click
file text tax to 33
789 that's tax to 33
7 89. david is in
lexington kentucky hi david welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave how you doing good how can i
help
okay i'm trying to make this as clear uh
as i possibly can so i don't use a lot
of time
uh well the situation is we have a
family member that
owns their own home but
due to some bad business choices when
she had a previous business
uh she got uh got into about a hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt with the
irs
and about 25 thousand dollars in back
property taxes
so we're just trying to see if this ship
can even
keep from being sunk due to this if we
were to try to help
what is the house worth the house is
estimated at around 190 thousand dollars
okay and so what does this person do for
a living now that their business has
failed
uh she works for italian marble company
i mean what kind of money should make uh
roughly around fifty thousand a year
okay
what's wrong with selling the house and
her renting and starting her life over
well that's what we was that's the
reason why i was calling you to see if
that would possibly be the best
outcome well the irs is going to take a
lien against it
okay if they haven't already and the
property taxes are a natural lien
against it
um yes you know she's lost this money
and i don't unless you haven't proposed
another way
for her to pay this all back has she got
some other hidden gem
somewhere that she could clear this up
and keep this house and see that i don't
i bet i don't think so dave
i don't either i don't think you'd have
been called yeah yeah
yeah you know and and that's the reason
why before we
try to get on board we don't want to get
on him how are you getting on board
well she had asked me to possibly
purchase the home
and her live in it yes
it's a it's a home up above and then
there's an apartment below
yeah so
you know what you know i'm calling
someone with all the knowledge that i
know that
this is going to steer me in in the best
direction do you not think that that's
going to end poorly
probably yeah probably i think we're
delaying the inevitable
and it might it might be that you end up
being the enemy at the end of this story
and i don't really want you
i don't want you to be the villain when
this is over yeah you know and
at my age i'm 62. i don't really want to
incur that much debt
uh at this time in my life you know i'm
trying oh you would have to go into debt
to buy it
yeah well some debt yeah um you know
that pretty much
that answers the question then doesn't
it yeah yeah
so the best thing for her is to take the
extra cash above the irs and above the
property
taxes that this house will yield and use
that to start her life again and to
start
yeah moving towards another home
purchase someday soon
and let's put her in the finance let's
put her into financial peace university
in ramsey plus i'll pay for it
and help her get her hands around money
um
we've all done stupid things that
brought pain into our life and she has
done that
and it's really sad but we really can't
keep the pain from happening it's going
to happen
and that's what that's what this move is
she's trying to keep
from experiencing the pain that she's
already signed up for
yeah yeah and you're going to go down
with it as the problem so now
i would ask her to sell the house but
not to you yeah
you know you know that this isn't the
right move every time we ask you
it's like asking you do you want to put
your hand in a bear trap you'd say no
so yeah you know like come on i
understand what's you're a good
dude and your heart feels for her but
this is pain that number one dave she
can get out of
and she should get out of and he should
not take her pain on
yeah there's no it doesn't serve any
purpose no it's a real clean transaction
to
just tell her to get with a real estate
elp and hang on i'll have kelly pick up
and we'll hook him up hook her up with
ramsay plus for a year
and let her go through financial peace
university let's get her let's be part
of her healing and her rebuilding
yeah cheer on rather than um uh
part of her denial yeah which in a sense
this is financial denial
that's what is is we're participating in
her acting like this
didn't happen total bailout yeah buy my
house and let me live in it and let me
live in it and then
you know and then i've still got all
these same habits and all the same
problem no
i think issues are on the way
linda's in springfield massachusetts hi
linda welcome to the ramsey
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
uh
i'm a new devotee i've discovered you
you're the only gift of cobra that i've
discovered
when i started working i feel blessed
already every single day
every single day from you know two to
five i have youtube on and i've been
listening every single day
thank you so i'd also like to give a
shout out to the live chat gang on
ramsey show
on the youtube channel yeah because um i
trip in there every so often so my
question
is um almost at the end of baby step
three
because i've been really you know trying
to implement your plan
right but i'm also i'm also in your age
group i'm 62
and nearing you know the age of
retirement i have a condo that needs
um i've been in it 20 plus 24 years or
so
and it needs a bit of work in different
areas now pre-dave i would have gone to
the bank and taken out a loan and then
hired somebody and said i got this much
money do what you can you know like
here's my list you know and do it but
since i'm gonna be
cash flowing these things i was
wondering if you could help me with
like order of operations as far as
hitting
repairs and rentals you know i don't
want to
have somebody come in and say like i
want to put some
additional um ambient lighting in
replace my kitchen floor replace my
kitchen cabinets
what i would do is get bids on these
individual things and the bids need to
include two things
one is the price of the thing you're
wanting to do
and so you've got a price to save for a
target to save for
and then the second thing you want is
how long the repair is going to take
and so um you know if ambient lighting
is
i don't make up a number of thousand
bucks and it takes two days
that's one level of repair kitchen
cabinets and floor
might be 15 thousand bucks and three
weeks i don't know i'm making up numbers
but
the different repairs are going to take
longer and cost more
and so you want to kind of stage those
in and then you can develop kind of a
project
list and then that's your savings list
that's your goal list that you're saving
up money to knock out
um and if you can just prioritize it and
think it through
but do it with real numbers go ahead and
get bids on the different items and keep
them
separate don't make it one big project
yeah i agree and you know
what i found and again she didn't say
anything about selling this thing but
it's always a good idea to get with a
ramsey
one of our real estate professionals and
just have them come in or talk to them
and say hey
what are some good changes to make that
always put me in a good position
sometimes we want to do things but it
may not matter that much so when you're
thinking about that too
think about resell or you know spend
money spend money on things that'll help
it go up in value
and help it sell not things that that
you know don't move the needle at all
and are very expensive so that's the
other thing you want to do with that
so i'll just make you a good incremental
project list and then you can arrange it
in whatever order you choose
with the help of the contractor good
question linda we're honored to have you
in the audience congratulations on your
success
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs a producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
ken coleman ramsey personality and a
host of the ken coleman show where he
talks with people about careers and jobs
all day long in 75 cities plus
a sirius xm show plus i uh youtube and
podcasts that are very very popular
so thank you thank you thank you for
joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two
two five blake is with us blake is
in raleigh north carolina hi blake how
are you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
been waiting on you to say that um so
i have a question um my wife and i uh
have wanted to build a house and um
every builder that we speak with
has quoted us way over budget
um so uh it seems that prices to build
are continuing to go up
and so we have started to look at
existing homes but those are also very
expensive
um we're currently renting a two bedroom
single wide trailer and we have
two children um so we're just kind of uh
we're kind of stuck we we could uh you
know pick a smaller house plan
um but you know right now i don't think
we would want to go much smaller than
what we've already chosen
so i'm just wondering if you think we
should wait it out
should we be looking at other homes um
just wanted to get your advice okay
and you're debt-free and you have your
emergency fund plus a down payment
yes sir good so you're ready to go well
i would continue to look this is your
first home purchase i take it
uh we actually sold our first home um in
august
and uh you know with hopes to do this
and so
when we sold we moved into this rental
house so this would be our second home
okay all right well in general here's a
couple things to take into the
formula okay number one uh
generally speaking with rare exceptions
used housing
is less expensive than new uh
new is usually the the top line
bar of how we set values in residential
real estate
and so you know you're going to get more
bang for your buck
with a used house in general and if
you're having trouble making something
fit your budget
then that's going to be part of your
answer for sure the second thing you've
got is
we are in a very very very unique time
right now
with the lumber factories being shut
down during covid there became a huge
shortage of lumber and lumber prices
have gone
up exponentially in the last little
while and the primary the largest
cost item on your p l are on your
project list as you're building a home
as lumber
and so uh we're even seeing builders in
some areas
uh not agree to lock in the price like
we'll build you a house for x
but if lumber goes up more we're going
to have an escalation clause in that
contract i'm hearing stuff like that
happening out there
okay and so um which i would not
sign up for that by the way because
steel is doing the same thing i got a
huge price increase
on a building i'm building next door our
uh
conference center that we're putting up
that we're breaking ground on next month
we just got the prices in and we've had
a huge increase on the steel steel's
done exactly the same thing so
uh the these unbelievable
high increases in prices on lumber and
steel are temporary
uh but will they ever come all the way
back down to where they were i don't
know
but it's a simple supply demand thing
that there was just not
any and everybody was chasing what few
is there and so when the supply dries up
and there's high demand it always drives
price up that's seventh grade economics
and so that's what you're facing on the
new home building side it's
it's uh one of the toughest times in
decades to build a new home right now
because of uh escalating prices on
uh on there all kinds of different
things and
there's this huge influx of people back
into the real estate market there's a
shortage of inventory in the real estate
market across the nation
to give you an idea february to february
february of
19 to february of 20 real estate went up
3.9
nationwide in value from february of 20
to february of 21 it went up 14.9
percent
well and so that's that's that's used
housing
but part of that is that riding the cap
of
the shortage of inventory and the
shortage of the lumber driving these
lumber prices up so if i'm in your shoes
i'm not going to ride it out now i'm
going to probably go and buy a used
house
i'm probably going to park my plans to
build
until some of the smoke clears on this
craziness that's out there
let this market balance back out a
little bit you'll be able to get better
attention from a builder
and you'll be able to get a a more
predictable reasonable price and that
might be three years
but in the meantime i don't want you in
that trailer i'd be i'd be buying
something that'd be my plan
yeah thanks for the call it's a crazy
time this stuff is
quite hot out there it really is but you
know there are some opportunities you
know i was reading a story recently of
the wall street journal of how a lot of
young couples are moving out of urban
areas and into suburbia and they're
buying older homes
that are still a good value but they're
what they're doing is is they're taking
their cash
and they're putting the cash into rental
so again we speak we preach cash on this
renovation yeah but if you can renovate
it and kind of make it more valuable
make it livable if it's livable to begin
with you know you got two little girls
here
yeah so depending on how short he is
they had planned to sell
and then buy you know just keep saving
and get pretty close but i would go the
used route too i agree with that just
because you can't go wrong there
yeah yeah well and you're either way you
know
whatever you do you need to be in the
ownership role
because it's going to go up it's right i
mean for a fifteen
fourteen point nine fifteen percent
increase in real estate prices in one
year
i haven't seen that i haven't seen that
since the 70s yeah when we had double
digit inflation
right and real estate was a big part of
that when i got in the real estate
business in 1978
they taught us when we're doing a a
comparative market analysis doing an
appraisal
that for every month that the comp was
old add one percent for increase in
value
so if it was a four month old comp you'd
add four percent that's a 12
annualized wow and uh of course that's
not happened in
decades and do you see it being how much
because i don't i think it's temporary
yeah because we're seeing this
because i mean it's all the supply
demand it was just this
pent up demand everybody's sitting
around looking at their house going i
hate this place
yeah and they hadn't spent that much
time at home before right and so they
put it on the market sold it and and
there's just a shortage is it also
because new home builds have slowed down
so once they speed back up now inventory
increases
and then pricing drops yep because you
couldn't get lumber are you worried
about a housing
bubble no why no
but because there's a shortage of
inventory that'll balance out
yeah this is not um this is natural
supply demand is what you're saying it's
not some false
it's not just a froth it's not a hyper
crazy people going nuts okay
just for the sake of going nuts um it's
a it's
it is too uh it is too many people
chasing too few houses
which is supply and demand and that
drives the price up so you know you hear
the stories of a house going on the
market i heard one in my neighborhood
this week that
the lady was telling my wife went on the
market and they sold and yeah you know
in four days and there were multiple
offers and
people offering more than appraisal
they're not even able to get it
appraised they gotta pay cash for it
because they can't get the appraisal on
it
wow um because there's the appraisals
haven't caught up with the
with the froth for the supply demand
that's driving this
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
st patrick's day brought some folks a
little luck this year on wednesday the
irs announced that it is pushing the
federal tax deadline back
everyone in the u.s now automatically
gets an extra month to file
with the date moved from april 15th to
may 17th
and that's for federal returns not
estimated quarterly payments
not state taxes and uh why do you get
pushed back well the pandemic's still
affecting things and when you throw in
the very recent tax changes the april
15th
deadline was looking like a lot of
trouble for the irs
and with the change to may 17th you have
an extra month to not just file
but to also pay your tax bill if you're
in texas oklahoma or louisiana your tax
date from the irs is still june 15th
because of the storms that hit you so
what does all this mean well it means
you have extra time to file your taxes
but
if you can file now especially if you do
a refund well you would go ahead and do
that obviously
now if you need help filing or other
online
either online or with a trusted tax
advisor we can help we can hook you up
with a tax advisor we can
hook you up with ramsey smart tax just
text tax to 33
789 text tax to 33789
evan is in idaho falls idaho hi evan
welcome to the ramsey show
uncle dave how are you better than i
deserve sir how can we help
i'm i'm here with my wife tyra and uh we
got a question for you
okay we've been on baby step now baby
step two
for some months now um we have
about seven thousand dollars in debt
that we're taking care of
and with a baby on the way yay
unfortunately some taxes we've got about
another five
coming down the line okay for
for more um debt and we
made the decision together that i'm
gonna go back to school at the end of
this year
so with debt and a baby and school
we're wondering where to focus our money
while being on step two
big step two
okay i'm um
it's incongruent for we made the
decision to go back to school
together at the end of the year if you
can't pay for it
when you're working to get out of debt
those two things don't work together
unless you can afford to pay for it
after you're out of debt what's your
household income
uh currently just over forty thousand
okay and so you need twelve thousand
dollars to pay off the five thousand
dollars in irs debt
and the seven thousand dollars in debt
and you need how much to go back to
school
um with three years of school
i anticipate maybe
no more than 10 a year so let's say 30
000
for school yeah and who's how who's
working dur you're working during this
time
um we will be so anticipated full-time
school part-time work
yes and how are you paying ten thousand
dollars a year and paying for your
family
we are anticipating
some grants now i guess you should know
if if those don't go through uh
getting a loan out for school is not an
option for us so
um what kind of agreement what kind of
grants are you anticipating
um the i was under the impression
that there's some grants out there to
help families go to school
and that now i don't know the math but i
was gonna
see if those are available and
then do the math to see what would what
it would cost and how much work would
have to be done
to continue why school why school i'm
just curious what's the reason for going
back to school
um uh the field that i'm interested in
requires a degree what family and
construction management no it doesn't
yeah that's
uh that's a complete and utter myth uh
dave knows a little something about
construction
um lots of people just could do
construction management all day long
without the degree and
yeah you could work your way up the
ladder you know that are you in
construction
i am yeah yeah so you basically said you
think you need a degree somebody's
convinced you or you just have this myth
out there that you need this degree to
lead people
in the construction business you're
already in the construction business so
let's set that aside for right now
what's the payoff date well as of before
you called you guys have been thinking
through this when were you planning to
pay the 12 off
um our calculator tells us
um what was the title you know uh
to get our debt taken roughly roughly i
think we're looking at
three years three years to pay 12 000
off well you know what you're right with
this new
with the baby bill and the taxes that
probably has increased by
a couple years no dude you missed what i
was getting at
that that's way too much to to pay off
that money yeah yeah that
this needs to be a matter of months not
a matter of years it's a small amount in
the grant and no you're not going back
to school to your debt free
no and um and no you probably don't need
to go back to school to do this
so all of this to say that helps with
the priorities a lot
um yeah uh uh you know i think you need
to do some more
is a four-year degree in construction
management
necessary for you to do construction
management no
it is not a precursor there's not a
licensing issue
there's not a problem with that you you
do have to have the knowledge to do
construction management and it's that a
way to get the knowledge yes it is a way
there are other ways for you to skin
this cat
and i would highly recommend you do the
other ways because you have a family to
feed and raise
at this point but dude you need a system
where you are
100 debt free in about
six months and that's going to involve
like two extra jobs
you're raising your household income and
getting on a tight budget if you made
fifteen hundred dollars a month
delivering pizza five nights a week
which you can do as an example uh you
would be debt free in just a matter of
months
if you threw all of that at the 12 000.
and um
and you got to get this irs whatever
caused this irs problem it has to stop
and so that means you're under
withholding or something else you did
that you can't do anymore but um
so here's your hint for the future we
don't need to make decisions that we
can't pay for
so we made the decision i'm going back
to school at the end of the year
but we have no freaking idea how we're
going to do it at this point except
these mythical grants that you have in
your mind that i don't think are out
there
i think you're gonna have trouble
finding those i hope you can find them
and i don't mind if you go to school and
pay for it but i don't i think you're
going through a lot of trouble to try to
increase your income and there's other
ways to do that on your career track
yeah first things first i mean i tell
people this on the on the ken combs show
look
we can pursue the dream once we get
financially stable and oh by the way
when we get financially stable meaning
getting out of debt getting the
emergency fund in place
and then having a plan to be able to
cash flow or getting qualified
uh you get there faster than if you try
to do it this way which is go to school
and i gotta say this dave i i
i gotta do a little rant here uh and
it's quick
but folks if education if
higher education isn't the only way
to do what you want to do or the best
way
then don't assume you have to do it so
ask the question do the research
if i want to be in construction
management be successful is a four-year
degree
the only way to do that no is it the
best way
i'm not even sure on that one to be
honest with you i have to do some
research i want to talk to winston your
son-in-law on that one
because i think if you get in the
business and you really figure out from
people that are construction managers
well i wrote the book the proximity
principle get around some people
sean uh who are doing this
excuse me evan i apologize evan get
around people that are actually
successful construction managers even
it's a phone call or a friend of a
friend of a friend and go hey
how would one how could i how can i get
the information i need without going to
get a four-year degree
what just humor me friend what would it
take to get there without a four-year
degree
you'd be surprised four classes at the
vo-tech school
on project management and on
construction technique to add to what
your knowledge you already have working
in the business you're probably there
and oh by the way you probably could
take on another construction job or
something
in this field right now and they would
pay off the 12 grand and if it depend on
the size of the company they might pay
for
you to take the classes to become one of
their managers you bet
yeah there's another that's your angle
it's not
stop your life and hope grants will
carry your little family along
that's a scary scenario you're painting
out there brother i wouldn't do that
i wouldn't wish that on my worst enemy
thanks for calling
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us this is the
ramsey show ken coleman ramsey
personality is my
co-host sean is with us in baton rouge
hi sean welcome
to the ramsay show thank you i'm calling
um i have a question about the baby
steps
we're at we're self-employed and we're
trying to get on board with the baby
steps and i was just wondering
should we only have a thousand dollars
being that we're self-employed for baby
step one or should we have more
you're not making any money are you
we i mean well last 2019 we
the adjusted growth income was 188 000
okay then why are you worried why are
you worried about only having a thousand
dollars if you're making 20 000 bucks a
month
i'm just trying to do the baby steps and
my husband
i know but i mean you're making 20 000 a
month why can't why are you worried
about having a thousand dollars
i don't know i just i'm trying to make
it make sense
to him i'm like well that i mean that's
that's a common sense question for him
yeah you have twenty thousand dollars a
month coming in why are you worried
about only having a thousand dollars you
got plenty of money coming in
i mean if the world if you had a major
emergency you would just twist turn and
use that 20 grand and work it out right
yeah yeah because i'm like i'm trying to
get him to use the cash that we have on
hand and he's like no and
keep this in case of an emergency yeah
so
he's also the one that got you into debt
yeah
so his best plans aren't real good ones
[Laughter]
you know because we do this uh not just
on radio stations all around the country
but we're on youtube you can actually
take him to this moment rewind and let
him just watch it for himself
yeah so how much debt have y'all got how
much debt have you all got honey
uh between the business and personal we
have like 229
000 what's on the business
the business is 110 that's like
that's lines of credit and a ppl loan
okay and uh what's the personal
the personal is 117 but that that
doesn't include the mortgage
and it's um it's a vehicle a heloc loan
the irs and a student loan
how much do you owe the irs 12
000 okay and what kind of net profit are
you making
on this 188 000 what'd you pay taxes on
that's what we paid the now the business
brought in
950 000. oh that's your actual profit
yeah yeah okay all right how long have
you been
how long have you guys been running this
business
it's nine years okay all right
well this is uh i i started our business
on a card table in my living room
and i coach we coach businesses through
our entree leadership brand all over
america and have for decades
and um i can tell you what's happening
here
okay just by the information that you've
given me and this is not i was kind of
poking fun
and being sarcastic a while ago but now
i'm concerned now i'm a little bit
concerned
okay you have irs debt
you're making clear close to 20
000 a month and you're so
discombobulated and confused and there's
so much chaos
so little organization your accounting
system sucks
that you still feel out of control
and this business it has grown so much
bigger than your ability to manage it
yes and so it's kind of like you feel
like you've gotten in a real powerful
car and you just learned how to drive
yeah i can hear it i can tell i can feel
the number i'm telling you i'm just like
what am i supposed to be doing here yeah
so
here's what we're gonna do i'm gonna
send you a copy of our book entree
leadership
on how to how to run a business it's
it's our playbook on how we've run our
business
it's not going to give you all the
information you need though you need to
get
with with a a different person
than you've been using to keep your
books
how many employees do you have none it's
just
we just have subs we uh it's a home
maintenance and remodeling business so
we don't have any employees we're just
we're 10.99 in the field
okay here's a book for you to pick up
too i'm going to give you two or three
assignments that are going to help you
with this because your
you're classic you have become very
successful
and your success is going to be your
doom is how it feels does that make
sense
yeah yes and i'm so proud of you you've
done so well
you and your husband okay this is a
great it's a great success story
but your lack of systems and your lack
of accounting
um is classic in your world
because your husband your husband is a
guy that can fix anything
he knows how to do any kind of
construction project and get it done
and he knows how to run the subs right
but he's done he hasn't ever learned and
and i had to do the same thing
and everybody that's in business said
learn to do the same thing you've got to
learn to run the business side of the
business
the second book is called the e-myth
e-myth
by gerber by gerber g-e-r-b-e-r
and michael gerber says in that book
that you have to learn to work
on your business not just in your
business
right and you guys have been working in
the business and growing it up
but you've never stepped back and put
the accounting systems in place to
control
the flow of the money because you've got
enough money to clean this mess up
really really fast when you get it
efficiently managed
that's what i that's how i can tell
that's how i can tell there's a bunch of
chaos
yeah yeah and you'll start you need to
start job costing each one of these jobs
separately
and that'll that probably involves an
estimating package
a good estimating package with a good
accounting software and so the third
assignment i'm going to give you two
books and an assignment
read those two books okay kelly if we if
we've got e-myth just ship it to her
if we don't just ship her the
information on how to get an e-myth book
but
um anyway then go to uh if you
go to daveramsey.com and click on tax
elp and find
one in your area there in baton rouge
that helps with bookkeeping
and have them come in not to fix it all
but to start to teach you and your
husband how to
do an accounting system properly run
that will help you get control of this
because this money
you're trying to out i did this for
years and so i'm not trying i'm not
making fun of you okay
because i've done the exact same thing i
tried to out earn my stupidity
right i tried to work hard enough make
so much money
that it overcame my lack of systems and
my lack of accounting prowess and my
lack of other things
and you run too big a business now to
not increase your sophistication
it leaves you vulnerable to failure uh
that you don't need to feel the stress
that you're feeling
i know you're making a lot of money and
you're working your butt off and you
could have a lot more peace
than you have right now so you
desperately need someone in the
accounting world
to come in and go okay here's what job
costing looks like here's what cash
management looks like
here's what an accounting system looks
like and whoever's been doing it before
you before has not been cutting it so
they're gone you've got to fire them
and you may need to hire someone as a
full-time
bookkeeper miniature cfo whatever we
want to call it controller
uh you know probably 60 70 000 a year
you could put somebody on
as a controller that could jerk a knot
in this tail pretty quick and get it all
straightened out and give you half your
life back
and you'd make more money as a result of
hiring them than they cost you that's
right they're spinning plates right now
and they've got to get some simplicity
that feels very complex
their business is fairly simple but i
think it's got all these moving parts
and what you're saying is right
once they simplify and get a really good
system
oh game changer now they know what to do
with the money now we can work the baby
steps and pay this debt off because the
beauty of
this is sean's husband is really really
good at making money
that's a fantastic it's a great business
yeah to be in
number one number two he's proven that
he's good at making it
the problem is that the thing's gonna if
you're not careful
it becomes very unstable like a house of
cards and it'll fall in on you that's
right because all the chaos
and the irs hadn't been paid we've got
all these other bills that hadn't been
paid off and we make plenty of money to
pay them all off
all right you could have cleared in no
time that's right and that's why he's
reaching and saying i need more money in
the savings
instead of a thousand dollars sure they
feel it yeah he needs he needs that pad
because he he has all this volatility
going on
and uh and all of that can go away with
some with some systems and some
processes
uh in in the accounting world and it's
really not rocket science it's
stuff you could do on a yellow pad if
you knew how to do it it's really not
that hard but
you just got to have someone teach you
and say this is how this works and this
is what you know you got to get this in
control and then let's lay out some cash
flow priorities
and let's begin to clear these debts up
you could clear them up very very
rapidly
you could be completely debt free in
your world in about two years
a hundred percent debt-free in two years
would that be wild that'd be wild
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today philippians 2 3
through 4 do nothing out of selfish
ambition
or vain conceit rather in humility value
others above yourselves not
looking to your own interests but each
of you to the interest of others
brian tracy says leadership is the
ability to get extraordinary achievement
from ordinary people ethan is with us
ethan
is not on that line he is on that line
in jacksonville florida hi ethan how are
you
i'm doing well mr angie how are you
doing better than i deserve what's up
um i was i just wanted to get some
advice
on what are some things that i should be
doing as a young person trying to
start my own company how young a person
17 okay what kind of company are you
trying to start at 17
uh a drone technology company
drone technology company to do what with
the drone technology
uh for for uh police surveillance
purposes
okay so you're gonna get police
departments to hire you
to help them with their drone technology
yes sir
okay um i'll play
hard to get for a second are you okay
with that
yes sir one of the problems you're gonna
have to solve is why would a police
department hire a 17 year old to do that
that is not a point
i'm not trying to be a dream killer dude
i'm just trying to present you with the
problems you're getting ready to face
okay trying to help you with your path
so i think that can be
done um and so uh uh
because you prob you know here's the
thing about drone technology it's a lot
like other technologies
old people are intimidated by it and we
always look for a teenager to tell us
how to fix it so that's the good news in
this story right
yes sir and so that that's one way to
open the door
but just to present yourself as tada
we're a big time drone technology
company
only for the local sheriff's department
to discover that a 17 year old running
the thing could cause you issues so
i think i want to back into this rather
than go
into it face forward and probably go in
and
help the local law enforcement people
for free for a little while
and to to where they get to where they
can't live without you what do you think
ken
yeah ethan i like the ambition i think
you're gonna have to actually
start doing some drone uh surveillance
have you been doing that
um i have purchased a few
model kits that i've put together and
tried putting my own spin on it with uh
different types of miniature cameras
yeah so you it's
this is you've got to create a body of
work so let's just start with
dave's absolutely right but let's start
at the very beginning here before we try
to
sell your business we got to show your
work there's a great book by a guy named
austin cleon named
show your work very simple book you read
in 10 minutes you've got to now that you
have these drone kits you got to get up
there in the air and you got to start
doing real estate maybe doing a nice
aerial of somebody's farm or something
if that doesn't get shot down you got to
be careful these days but you've got to
show your work and begin to show the
video quality of what you can do with a
drone
and so from a crime fighting perspective
um ethan you've thought about this i
never have
how is a drone used
well uh basically if if a
if if the police were storming said
building
they could use a drone with uh
hot with a high definition 4k camera to
follow
suspects that might leave the building
or they could use a uh thermal camera
attachment to try and gauge
how many heat signatures were inside the
building so they could get a better
understanding on who was all in there
and what happened i thought you had
thought about this
okay good so here's here's your body of
work it's not just flying over a farm
okay you get six of your buddies uh you
find
uh a friend that has an abandoned house
on a farm somewhere or something
and you go uh stage how you would use
this and make your buddies be the bad
guys and the good guys
yes and you you give you show a police
al you show a
police professional a a crime fighting
professional how you would have done
this
and if you have two or three of those
pieces of tape uh
you know i i would just waltz in to the
local guy's office and say hey
um i've really i really think i can help
you guys i know i look like i'm
17 because i am but i want you to watch
this for just a second or if your dad
knows somebody
there at the police department that'll
give you a hearing and let you just
give me five minutes let me show you
what we did and you show him how
someone's life got saved or how a bad
guy get captured got captured or
whatever the benefit of this
is with a staged scenario with some of
your buddies playing
cops and robbers so to speak um and then
when they see the benefit of it they
don't care how old you are
yes yeah but i do want to go back to
what i'm saying i think that's great i
think it's a bit of a hail mary though
and i like that i say go for it
but i still think you if you want to
start a business with a drone
then let's let's let's crawl a little
bit let's start making some money you
know i know a lot of kids actually know
kids in this area that are doing drone
work for real estate
professionals oh yeah so they're young
people ariel of properties well i know
there's lots of drone work been done but
they're all
one kid's 24 and other kids 19. you know
i'm saying
i want him to just start making some
money with drones
period while he's doing the same thing
while you're trying to do this highly
sophisticated crime fighting
drone yeah because the only question
mark i have for you ethan and i have for
myself is
do most sheriff's departments i mean how
widespread is the usage of
drones right now i don't know either i
don't know i think your metropolitan
areas though they do it it's a cool
thing yeah
so ache build a body of work b try to
find a contact
through a friend that will give you a
hearing c
go make some money in something that's
not necessarily crime fighting with
drones to prove that you have a business
and use all of that as a as you
beginning to build your entrepreneurial
experience i'm with ken
i love your ambition i just want you to
fight through the troubles so ethan the
reason i ask a question like that is
this
three weeks after i turned 18 years old
i got my real estate license
three weeks later i sold my first house
to a guy i knew from high school
and he was the only one that would talk
to me about a house right because i was
18 years old who buys a house from an 18
year old kid right a very good point
yeah and so
i i spent the next four years of my life
while i was in college selling real
estate
fighting the uphill battle of being an
extremely
young extremely young real estate agent
and i've laughed about this before but i
grew out of mustache my little tom
selleck mustache back in those days
magnum piano i got to get my hands on
one of those pics you got to get that
pick
and i had the disco suit because disco
as big as the only only suit i had
i never real suit bell bottoms uh well
sort of but they're kind of john
travolta look you know okay
all right so i'm out showing houses with
my tom selleck mustache and uh
you know and but i still sold some
houses because i was like ethan i was
ambitious and i was just going to
scratch and claw and make it happen
and the experience was valuable but i
was so
uh sure of myself
that would be an understatement yes that
it never occurred to me
that this was going to be an uphill
battle to get people to buy houses from
an 18 or a 19 year old
young person and it was a huge battle
and so i just and and you know people
try to tell me you can't do it and i did
it anyway so i'm not telling you you
can't do it ethan you can do it anyway
but i don't want you to miss the fact
that because sometimes guys that are in
the technology they think the technology
is going to make the sale for them
and you know they've got to know who's
running the freaking drone back there
yeah you got to show your work
now again if you show your work and your
work is good
you're eventually going to get some
yeses and and there will be people who
always discount your youth
so what do you have to do dave just said
it you've got to
show that hey this is the quality that i
can do and here's why i want you to just
do any job you can with a drone right
now i want you get some momentum i want
you get some momentum in the form of
money
when you're joining the sheriff's
department say i'm already making good
money doing this this and this but i
really have a bent for this crime thing
yeah
and you know it's not like you're my
first client
that's right you know you're you're my
18th client uh you're just my first
crime-fighting
yeah client i love the long pass the
hail mary go for it don't put yourself
offer to help them for free i can't say
that enough you're exactly
right yes you know for if you're making
money over here doing
real estate or whatever dronage right
drone each there you go
you just came up with a whole new camera
but anyway you're over there making
money doing that so you can afford to go
into a a live crime situation and help
them and
prove your worth and do it for free two
or three times
then they will get you into their little
government budget to keep you around and
you may have just started a big hairy
deal
that's pretty cool yeah i love the idea
very fun
i just don't know much about it so i
fumble around wander through the clouds
well you didn't fumble dave you created
a whole new industry it's called
dronish droning that's it ah
thanks to james childs our producer
kelly daniel our associate producer and
phone screener i am dave ramsey your
host we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus hey it's kelly associate
producer and phone screener for the
ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit daveramsey.com
show and register we would love for you
to come to nashville and tell your story
you